WE CAN'T THANK THE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO HAVE SERVED ENOUGH AND WE
THANK YOU TO IMPLEMENT ALSO.
MANY LAWMAKERS ACROSS
CAPITOL HILL ARE PRAISING THE
PRESIDENT'S MEASURED RESPONSE.
I APPRECIATE PRESIDENTS DESIRE
TO BE MEASURED AND THOUGHTFUL.
MIKE FLORIDA, AND MICHAEL WALTZ,
WHO IS ALSO FROM FLORIDA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING.
THE VANTAGE POINTS ON THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE IS ALSO
VERY IMPORTANT ONE IN ADDITION
TO ARMED SERVICES.
THERE IS AN IMPORTANT DATE WHICH
IS JULY 8TH WHICH IS THE
DEADLINE THAT IRAN HAS PUT OUT,
THEY PICKED A NUMBER, THEREFORE
YOU'RE UP TO HELP GET OUT OF THE
AS IRANIAN SANCTIONS THAT ARE
CRIPPLING THEIR ECONOMY.
GIVE US YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN IRAN AND THE
PRESSURE THEY ARE FEELING FROM
ECONOMIC SECTION MICAH
SANCTIONS.
>> SECRETARY POMPEO HAS
DESCRIBED HIS MAXIMUM PRESSURE
CAMPAIGN WISHES TO BRING IRAN
BACK TO THE TABLE TO RENEGOTIATE
THE JCPOA, THE NUCLEAR DEAL.
THAT THIS ADMINISTRATION STEPPED
OUT OF.
OBVIOUSLY THE GOAL IS THAT WE DO
NOT WANT TO HAVE A NUCLEAR IRAN.
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE STEEL
NEEDS TO BE NEGOTIATED.
WHAT'S INTERESTING AND
CAPITOL HILL, THE PRESIDENT IS
TRYING TO SHOW RESTRAINT AND SO
THIS IS AN INTERESTING DEBATE
HAPPENING IN CONGRESS, WATCHING
THE PRESIDENT AS THE DEMOCRATS
CLAIM HE IS TRYING TO TAKE US TO
WAR.
HE'S SHOWING RESTRAINT AND
TRYING TO TAKE US TO THE
BARGAINING TABLE.
BE ONE CONGRESSMAN WALTZ, YOU
ARE A FRESHMAN THERE BUT YOUR
MILITARY SERVICE GIVES YOU AN
INTERESTING PERSPECTIVE.
FOLLOWING UP ON WHAT CONGRESSMAN
TURNER WAS TALKING ABOUT, WHAT
IS THE ATMOSPHERE?
WHAT ARE DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS ALIKE TALKING ABOUT
ON CAPITOL HILL?
>> I'VE OPERATED AGAINST THE
IRANIANS ON THE GROUND AND DEALT
WITH THEM FROM PREVIOUS SERVICE
IN THE WHITE HOUSE AND I CAN
TELL YOU THE UNDERLYING PREMISE
HERE IS WHAT WE HAVE TO AGREE O
ON.
WHETHER IT'S ISIS IN IRAQ,
IRANIAN BACKED TERRORISTS, WE
HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF THAT ABROAD
IN PLACES LIKE DAMASCUS, TEHRAN
AND KABUL, OR IT WILL FOLLOW US
HOME.
WE HAVE TO STAY ON OFFENSE AND
WHILE I ABSOLUTELY RESPECT TO
THE PRESIDENTS RIGHT AS
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF, WHAT ALL
THREE OF US HAVE FOUGHT FOR ON
THE ARMED SERVICES COMMITTEE,
HIS RIGHT TO GIVE THESE GREEN
LIGHT, GO AND NO-GO DECISIONS,
WE DO HAVE TO RESPOND.
IT'S DETERRED BY STRENGTH, AND
THE PRESIDENT I FULLY SUPPORT IN
KEEPING THE MAXIMUM PRESSURE
CAMPAIGN GOING.
I THINK HE MADE IT VERY CLEAR,
HE'S GOING TO DRIVE IT BACK TO
THE TABLE BUT GET A BETTER DEAL
IN THE LONG RUN.
AND THAT'S ABSOLUTELY WHAT HE
NEEDS TO DO.
>> Jason: CONGRESSMAN GAETZ,
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING AND SEEING
FROM YOUR COLLEAGUES ON THE
FLOOR OF THE HOUSE?
NOT EVERYBODY THINKS LIKE WHAT
CONGRESSMAN WALZ AND TURNER JUST
ARTICULATED.
>> I HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR MY
FELLOW FLORIDIAN COME MICHAEL
WALTZ.
BUT I THINK WHAT'S NAIVE, WHAT
ENGAGING IN UNFOCUSED,
UNCONSTITUTIONAL REGIME CHANGE
WARS IS EFFECTIVE IN THE MIDDLE
EAST OR BACK HOME.
YOU LOOK AT AFGHANISTAN, WE ARE
DOWN FROM HAVING THE AFGHAN
GOVERNMENT CONTROLLING 72% OF
THEIR ADMINISTRATIVE DISTRICTS
256% OF THEIR ADMINISTRATIVE
DISTRICTS IN THE LAST TWO YEARS.
YOU LOOK AT THE $6 TRILLION THAT
YOU SPEND IN THE REGION AND YOU
THINK THAT'S LARGER THAN THE
MARKET CAP OF FACEBOOK, GOOGLE,
AND AMAZON COMBINED.
I THINK AN AMERICAN FIRST
FOREIGN POLICY ADVANCED BY THE
PRESIDENT IS ONE THAT WOULD
PRIORITIZE GETTING THE GULF
CARTEL OUT OF THE SOUTHWESTERN
UNITED STATES BEFORE WE DECIDE
THAT WE WILL BE THE POLICEMAN OF
THE GULF OF OMAN.
IF YOU HAVE JAPAN AND NORWAY NOT
SEEKING WORK FOR VESSELS OWNED
BY FOLKS IN THEIR COUNTRIES
BEING ATTACKED, I DON'T THINK
IT'S THE JOB OF THE
UNITED STATES TO AVENGE FOREIGN
VESSELS OR ROBOTS, WITH
PATRIOTS.
>> I DON'T THINK YOU WOULD
NECESSARILY AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING CONGRESSMAN GAETZ
JUST SAID, WHAT DO YOU?
>> I THINK JASON WHEN WE HAVE
THIS DEBATE, ENEMY SELF SELECT
AND THE MOST IMPORTANT THING WE
CAN DO IS HAVE THE STRONG
MILITARY AND A PRESIDENT THAT IS
NOT RESTRAINED AND ABLE TO TAKE
ACTION.
THE DEBATE UNFORTUNATELY IN THE
HOUSE OF THE LAST TWO WEEKS, AND
THE LAST TWO WEEKS THE DEMOCRAT
VOTED TO REPEAL THE 2001
AUTHORIZATION OF THE USE OF
FORCE THAT WAS PASSED AFTER 9/11
THAT ALLOWED US TO GO AFTER
AL QAEDA AND ISIS AND JUST LAST
WEEK THERE WAS DEBATE ABOUT
RESTRICTING THE PRESIDENT'S
ABILITY TO RESPOND TO IRAN WHICH
WOULD HAVE PREVENTED THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
FROM RESPONDING EVEN IF IRAN
ATTACKED ISRAEL.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT ENEMIES
SELF-SELECTED AND HAVE A STRONG
MILITARY TO PROTECT OUR COUNTRY.
>> Jason: IS A PRESIDENT DOING
WHAT HE SUPPOSED TO BE DOING
HERE?
IS THAT WHAT HAS HAPPENED SO
FAR?
>> ALL THREE OF US ABSOLUTELY
AGREE, MAINTAINING OPTIONS FOR
THE PRESIDENT AND NOT ALLOWING
THE PRESIDENT TO TIE HIS HANDS
FOR POLITICAL REASONS.
HE IS COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF,
CONGRESS DOES HAVE A ROLE IN
LINE WITH THE WAR POWERS ACT BUT
AT THE END OF THE DAY, AND IN
RESPONSE TO MY GOOD FRIEND
REPRESENTATIVE GATES, AT THE END
OF THE DAY WE HAVE TO FIGHT THIS
ABROAD.
I DON'T WANT TO FIGHT THIS IN
THE UNITED STATES.
WHEN HALF THE WORLD TERRORIST
ORGANIZATIONS EXIST IN
AFGHANISTAN, WHEN ISIS IS
SENDING AND RECOGNIZING REFUGEES
INTO EUROPE AND THE
UNITED STATES, AND WHEN IRAN IS
OPENLY SEEKING TO ATTACK ISRAEL
AND TO BUILD A NUCLEAR WEAPON TO
ATTACK ALL OF IT, IT'S ONLY IN
THE UNITED STATES THAT CAN LEAD.
AND WHENEVER WE WITHDRAW LIKE
OBAMA DID OUT OF IRAQ, AND LIKE
OBAMA DID TRIED TO DO OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN, BAD THINGS HAPPEN.
IF WE DON'T LEAD THEN WE LEAVE
THE WORLD OPEN TO CHINA AND
RUSSIA AND ISLAMIC EXTREMISM.
THAT DOES NOT MEAN WE HAVE HALF
A MILLION TROOPS ON THE GROUND,
THERE IS LOT OF SPACE BETWEEN
KUMBAYA WORLD PEACE AND A
MILLION SOLDIERS ON THE GROUND.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT
NEEDS TO BE REPRESENTING RIGHT
NOW.
>> Jason: SO IS DONALD TRUMP,
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES DOING THE RIGHT
THING OR DO YOU THINK HE'S
TAKING THIS STEP ALONG THE WAY?
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
MINDFUL AND EFFECTIVE.
THE ONLY REASON THESE STRIKES
DIDN'T OCCUR IS THAT THE
PRESIDENT WANTED TO MAKE SURE WE
GIVE PEACE A CHANCE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP UNDERSTANDS WE
GET PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH BUT
WE CAN ALSO ACHIEVE STRENGTH
THROUGH RESTRAINT.
I DON'T GET IT.
THE MIDDLE EAST REPRESENTS 3.5%
OF GLOBAL GDP AND WE ARE
OBSESSED WITH THIS AREA OF THE
WORLD.
CHINA REPRESENTS 15% OF GLOBAL
GDP AND THEY HAVE EXPANDED THEIR
EMPIRE WITHOUT FIRING A SINGLE
SHOT.
I THINK WE DO NEED TO REFORM THE
2001 AUTHORIZATION TO USE
MILITARY FORCE BECAUSE IF BRAVE
PATRIOTS ARE WILLING TO GO FIGHT
AND DIE IN THESE WARS, MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS OUGHT TO HAVE THE
GUTS TO VOTE FOR THEM OR AGAINST
THEM AND MAKE SURE WE FOLLOW THE
CONSTITUTION AND THE APPLICATION
OF MILITARY FORCE.
BUT THE PRESIDENT HAS SHOWN HIS
MINDFUL AND EFFECTIVE.
>> Jason: THE DEBATE WILL
CONTINUE BUT I THINK IT'S NAIVE
TO SAY CHINA NEVER FIRED A SHOT.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS VISIT WITH
THE VIETNAMESE AND OTHERS AS I
HAVE DONE IN CONGRESS.
BUT IN THE LAST 12 MONTHS, --
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT IF YOU LOOK
HARDER AT WHAT THE CHINESE ARE
DOING, --
>> .
I DO THINK THAT THE RIGHT ANSWER
TO THIS IS, IF PROVOKED, THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
HAS CLEAR AUTHORITY, IF THERE'S
CLEAR AND PRESENT DANGER, TO
TAKE WHATEVER ACTION HE NEEDS
TO.
IF HE'S GOING TO TAKE A LONG
TIME MORE THAN HE SHOULD GO TO
CONGRESS AND SHOULD GET THAT